okay
now i labored that point because
asymptotes are tricky right
and there's more to asymptotes that we
still haven't learned yet but this is
enough for now
okay we'll get some more interesting
intercepts
intercepts how do i find intercepts if i
want an x-intercept for instance i would
let y equal zero wouldn't i okay so if i
said okay um y equals zero so i'm going
to get
x squared plus one on x equals
zero when you're trying to find a
y-intercept right the denominator
doesn't matter
does it right so long as you get zero on
the top on the numerator as long as you
had zero up there
i don't care what's on the bottom you
can add zero of two zero five zero
minus three zero over a rock melon you
still get zero okay
so therefore all i'm interested in is
when's that numerator when's that zero
and the answer is the answer is it's
never equal to zero there's no value no
real value of x you can throw in there
that will make the numerator zero so
where are the y intercepts
uh sorry i should have said x intercepts
where are the x and steps there aren't
any
okay um now to find y intercepts i let x
equal zero
right so when i let x equal zero
i can't let x equal zero so where are
the y intercepts answer
there aren't any okay so i have no
intercepts so that's not very helpful
like
like i said you're gonna need a lot of
different examples to see the useful
things here
okay um so now
now what do i do here okay i know that
i'm gonna be constrained between these
two
i know i'm never gonna touch either of
the axes
okay so then you have a question can you
have a question
there are a couple of different places
that graph could go okay
for instance i could put the graph up
here that's one option right
by the way i'm only going to care about
this side because once i get this side
it's an odd function so i'll know where
the other side goes you're content with
that
okay now that's one option and that
obeys the asymptotes that i have
that's a bit naughty make sure you have
those
equations there now that's one option
but it's not the only option
it's not the only thing that this graph
can do and obey the two asymptotes i've
given it
what else could it do yeah
brandon how would you how would you wet
it
yeah okay instead of on the left of this
oblique asymptote i could be
on the right it would look like this i
guess
if i wanted to approach both asymptotes
right
yes ah very good so how do i know which
one's which
well in order to be this one i must
collide with
the x-axis but we've already determined
that we can't do that
right so therefore we can rule out this
version over here okay i'm going to rub
it out now
i know it can't go there because it
would do something that i know
it can't do namely have an x-intercept
okay so therefore my only option
is this guy up here
okay now i've got that
and because that's odd i have this part
down here
okay please be watchful just like in
like logs and that kind of thing or any
other kind of place where you've got an
asymptote
please make sure you don't trap yourself
by putting more information on than you
should
um just put your pens down and look up
at this i see many students
who for example see my graph how it
stops kind of here
but my asymptote i've drawn it to over
here so i see students who say oh
i should just i should just keep going
until until like the end right but
because
it gets increasingly more difficult to
draw accurately as you get
closer and closer students kind of end
up doing like this
and it wiggles or even worse
it doesn't wiggle it actually goes away
just just gently now just look at that
right
the difference is very minor isn't it
like it might be a millimeter or two
on your page but this is no longer
correct is it
right why not because it's not
approaching
it's not approaching anymore right so my
asymptote it's like i'm there just for
sure
just to be pretty right i'm not actually
approaching it that's that's posted
you're much better stopping your graph
there it's still asymptotic okay
all right are we finished yes
um how do you know how like deep you do
the things do you mean like
like here or here yeah okay good
question
uh and which which goes right into my
next thing there is one thing missing
from this or possibly
two uh mainly as we've involved a point
for scale
right because this at the moment is
exactly the same graph
as this right it will look exactly the
same
or this or this
right they're all the same i've just put
a vertical stretch
on it okay so therefore to tell the
difference between there's a genetic
point for scale
okay what would you suggest as a point
for scale one
one two x equals one would work so when
i put in x equals one into here
i get y equals one plus one over one
which is just
two okay so i know roughly where i am
now
here's the tricky part though okay can
you see how this graph
it's coming down it's decreasing and
then at a certain
point it turns around and it starts to
increase
you see that okay so we call this
because it's coming down and then it
turns
and goes up we call that that guy there
we call it a
turning point right because that's a
point where the graph turns
okay some names are very very common
sense they aren't all but anyway okay
now here's the thing though to work out
where it turns to work out where it
turns there you need one of two things
you either need calculus you need to be
able to differentiate this thing
or you need to know what a discriminant
is for this particular graph you can use
the discriminant in quadratics
to work out where it actually turns okay
now we will learn all of those
in time but for now you don't need to
know
you're not expected to know either of
those two things so therefore you're not
expected to know where that actually is
okay so you can call that one two and
that's close enough
okay now by the way that implies because
it's an odd function i have another
point for scale now don't i which is
negative negative one negative two right
down here so you wouldn't get one
if that wasn't the exact spoiler not yet
not yet okay because the time will come
and i'll even do it
i'll even do it today where you can work
out where those points are
and you can work it out precisely it's
not hard okay uh and once you know that
you will be expected to put it on
accurately okay